these russian soldiers were wounded in
the fighting in ukraine they are shown
here attending a music concert held in a
hospital
in another hospital deputy defense
minister alexander fuhrman awards the
wounded with medals for their service
the plan is to return home as soon as
possible and to continue with my career
as a civilian to study
i wish for peace in the whole world
honestly
because the current situation affected
not just me
my father's in the military my
grandparents in the military
president vladimir putin has also
praised members of the national guard
taking part in what russia describes as
a special operation in the donbass
region of southeastern ukraine
comrades indeed combat conditions
involve increased risk
i'm well aware of how you act in this
situation highly courageously and
professionally skillfully and fearlessly
you resolve the most complicated tasks
set before you competently and precisely
while showing personal heroism
russia has dismissed reports its
operation has been stalled the minister
of defense said its military campaign is
running as planned weakening ukraine's
military capabilities and paving the way
for its forces to focus more on
liberating areas in the donbass region
leonid pasnick leader of the
self-proclaimed lugansk people's
republic in eastern ukraine is now
saying he plans a referendum on the
separatist region's reunification with
russia
what will be the future of our republic
i think that in the near future a
referendum will be held on the territory
of the republic in which the people will
exercise their absolute constitutional
right and express their opinion on
joining the russian federation i'm
absolutely sure that this will be the
case last month russia formally
recognized lugansk and donetsk as
independent republics
moscow warns its operation will only end
when ukraine becomes what it calls a
neutral state acknowledges crimea as
part of russia and recognizes the
self-proclaimed republics of lugansk and
donetsk
al jazeera moscow